>> WELCOME BACK TO THE INGRAM
ANGLE.
TODAY WE VISIT IN A LOCAL PUB
WITH NIGEL.
>> I JUST WALKED INTO A PUB.
LOOK I WALK IN A PUB AND LOOK
WHAT YOU RUN INTO.
>> THE REPUTATION IS TRUE.
>> EXACTLY.
>> TODAY WE WERE AMONG SOME OF
THE PROTESTERS, SEVERAL THOUSAND
PEOPLE, MAYBE 10,000 PEOPLE IN
TRAFALGAR SQUARE.
THERE WERE COMMUNIST,
SOCIALISTS, AND PEOPLE WHO ARE
JUST ANTI-TRUMP IN THE MOST
VEHEMENT WAY.
THEY WERE ANTI-TRUMP,
ANTI-BREXIT, ANTI-NIGEL.
>> PLEASED TO BE IN THAT.
IF MY NAME WASN'T THERE, I WOULD
BE SO UPSET.
YOU TALK ABOUT PROTESTERS.
THEY'RE WHO I CALL THE USUAL
SUSPECTS.
THEY ARE THE PEOPLE -- ARE THEY
INCLUDING MY MEETINGS, OF
COURSE, BUT AMONG THEM, MORE
SIGNIFICANTLY WAS ONE JEREMY
CORBIN.
SO HERE'S THE GUY WHO COULD BE
THE NEXT BRITISH PRIME MINISTER
AFTER THE NEXT ELECTION.
AFTER ATTENDING A STATE BANQUET
AT BUCKINGHAM PALACE, HE'S AT
TRAFALGAR SQUARE, 70 YEARS OLD,
ALMOST LIKE A LEFT WING STUDENT
POLITICIAN.
HE JUST DOES NOT LOOK LIKE A
PRIME MINISTER IN THE EYES OF
PEOPLE.
SO I WELCOME THEY'LL LOSE IN A
BIG WAY.
>> Laura: YOU SEE THE PRESIDENT
WITH THERESA MAY TODAY, OUTGOING
PRIME MINISTER.
IS THAT REALISTIC GIVEN THE FLUX
THAT WE'RE IN.
>> COMPLETELY REALIST INGE.
I HAVE TO SAY I'M TIRED OF
CONVERSATION.
SHOULD WE TALK ABOUT A TRADE
DEAL, I THINK IT'S TIME TO ACT.
I THINK IT'S TIME WE FORM A
COMMITTEE OF INDUSTRIALIST MEN
AND WOMEN.
AMERICANS DO THE SAME.
WHY DON'T WE WORK ON THIS.
>> FOR PEOPLE IN THE UNITED
STATES WHO DON'T QUITE
UNDERSTAND IT, IT'S VERY
DIFFERENT FROM OUR OWN.
COULD YOU FORM A COALITION, A
BREXIT PARTY, ONLY STARTED TWO
MONTHS AGO WITH THE CONSERVATIVE
PARTY.
IT HAD A TERRIBLE SHOWING IN THE
EU NATIONAL ELECTIONS NEXT WEEK.
>> A LOT OF PERMATIONS THERE.
ONE IS THAT THE CONSERVATIVE
PARTY CONTINUES TO FAIL ON
BREXIT AND YOU CAN SEE THE DEATH
OF A PARTY.
THESE THINGS HAPPEN.
MORE REALISTICALLY, THEY'LL GET
A LEADER WITH A LITTLE BIT MORE
COURAGE.
>> Laura: WHO IS IT?
>> IT COULD BE -- BORIS TALKS A
BIG GAME.
BUT OFTEN DOESN'T DELIVER.
>> Laura: BORIS JOHNSON?
>> HE'S A GREAT PERSONALITY.
PEOPLE KNOW HIM.
WE HAVE TO SEE WHO EMERGES OUT
OF THIS.
THE GREAT BATTLE OF THE WEST.
GLOBALISM VERSUS NATIONALISM.
THAT'S THE DEBATE GOING ON.
THE ISSUE OF OUR TIMES AND THE
EPICENTER IS HERE IN LONDON
RIGHT NOW.
I CAN TELL YOU, HAVING BEEN
25 -- YOU KNOW THIS, I SPENT 25
YEARS FIGHTING FOR THIS.
I AM ABSOLUTELY CERTAIN THAT
BRITISH PUBLIC OPINION IS WITH
US.
THE BRITISH MIDDLE CLASS HAVEN'T
QUITE WOKEN UP TO IT.
BUT I'M GOING MAKE SURE THEY DO.
>> Laura: FLASH FORWARD -- JOE
BIDEN SOMEHOW WINS THE
NOMINATION, HE WINS THE
NOMINATION BUT HE ENDS UP
WINNING THE PRESIDENCY.
WHAT WOULD THAT MEAN TO THE
GLOBALIST INFLUENCE IN EUROPE.
THEY'D BE THRILLED, WOULD THEY
NOT BE, TO GO BACK TO BUSINESS
AS USUAL.
>> WE'RE ON THE RIGHT TRACK.
BUT, I FEEL THAT IF BREXIT WAS
TO FAIL, THAT WOULD BE THE
LIKELIHOOD OF BIDEN WINNING MORE